yeah and that's why I'm also trying to
quit cigarettes right now two days yeah
oh really it's for two days yeah so I
can see an edge oh yeah
and we'll suck somebody's dick for a
[ __ ] just a rumor of menthol but not
you buddy nobody who doesn't want it
okay never him though right you know I
can never imagine something your dick
Gilbert think I would laugh too much
while sucking your dick no I feel the
opposite that you would start grabbing
hair I don't I think that men don't know
how to grab hair properly and that's my
thing there's a properly and if not
proper way to do it you're gonna do it
grab it by the base and pull a lot of it
don't grab it by the ends and then just
pull chunks of it like you need to have
intention and direction yeah you know
what I do I go to the end guy curled it
he told me he was like oh you're a gay
man yeah yeah you know what I'd like to
do is I like to feel the skull oh wow
and take my fingernails and make it a
little indentation inside the skull so
there's a little there little bleeding
going on I just grab it like it's a
[ __ ] yeah you know means soft
watermelon yeah and I just grab it right
this and then I do yeah I put [ __ ] uh
conditioner in my hand oh yeah put it on
the hair lightly like that sleepy is
that sleeping koala that's good no I
don't like I'm a piece I don't even come
anymore if I'm having sex you know I'm
not coming I'm out of here
yeah you've stopped before oh I stopped
all the time if I'm at yeah that if for
anymore for me if I'm involved in the
sex but I'm not coming I'm out of there
I think it's old-fashioned I'm gonna
come around here and leave so my dear
enough Forensic Files to know that you
come in your own car on the way home
right it's old-school coming it's
old-school it's what you're saying
yeah or I'll come it yeah you just see
me back in the day coming up just
busting the other side of a Conestoga
wagon yeah yeah
yeah so you you get to the point of
coming yeah you make L Rauh lighter
around the point you know yeah yeah be
out there doing jumping jacks I don't
yeah but I'm not busting that's for me
yeah you got to really be somebody
special if I'm gonna calm at your house
[Laughter]
yeah you're not getting this freaking
free spunk yeah and here's the thing
dude it's like just in case you come in
the place yeah
and then you leave and all of a sudden
she gets murdered yeah now you're comes
all over the place right rapist a not a
rapist - yeah but your comes all over in
her eyes and how about the Scott this
the marks on her skull with the
fingernail in a yeah right and all of a
sudden I'm in prison for life right oh
did I wonder how you would be in prison
I wonder why would be a walking hole
yeah
it would just be look at that is that a
black hole and then they look at my face
you know that's Bobby's ass it would
just be dude people would just be to
carry your ass in boats uh I guess you
can you would just walk in yeah yeah
would ya like yeah like it's a dress
like I'm bowing at like a ball curtsy
yeah those are my ass cheeks
yeah I think that I would be a bat flies
out of it but I people are telling ghost
stories outside of a little lantern
[Laughter]
that's fine but I think that like if you
saw my cell though yeah I've have stacks
of cigarettes oh yeah right I have all
wine like I have all the things because
I'm gonna part her yeah I'm gonna
partner for my butthole oh yeah yeah
he's a little
[Laughter]
but I bet I bet after a while right but
it's like an orange like safety valve
people know everyone knows scuse me
walking yeah that's good yeah I think I
would survive though don't you think
yes you would survive I couldn't see
anybody killing you you don't seem of
the count